what is going on there citizens of the
rejack nation we just got out of
watching Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny and I just got out of I mean
like 15 minutes ago we saw it at a
theater nearby once we found a
reasonably quiet spot to set up and film
it
there were literally popo right around I
was like I'm dealing with this Burbank
today especially for this movie we're
just gonna go to my backyard still do it
standing so it feels a little bit more
like we just got out of the theater so
ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead
Fred's a friend's friend hey Whip that
like button before we go into our review
for this let's give you guys a little
plot synopsis of what this movie's all
about all right so Indy is old he's like
really old but he's got his trademark
for Dora and his whip at the ready
because he's on a mission to retrieve a
powerful artifact that could shake the
very foundations of history but he's not
alone on this Quest joined by his
goddaughter Indy's got more than just
ancient booby traps and deadly foes to
contend with he's got to keep up with a
whip smart young companion who's just as
eager to uncover the secrets of the past
and speaking of foes watch out for
Jurgen Vala this former Nazi might work
for NASA now but he's still up to his
old Nazi tricks you Nazis and he'll stop
at nothing to get his hands on the dial
of Destiny it's a Race Against Time as
Indian as goddaughter they never these
treacherous ruins sort of and outwit
their enemies sort of will they retrieve
the dial of Destiny before it's too late
did it warn unless the mediocre five
minutes Standing Ovation at Cannes Film
Festival we're here to tell you right
now if it does we only talked about it
during the credits we didn't ride
together to the theater I was thinking
about how we could structure this to
convey our appearances if we're mainly
on the same page but there's one thing
we're not really on the same page about
I feel like the best way to go about it
is to go through it act by Act of the
emotional experience we were feeling
through it John do you remember in
Indiana Jones Raiders of the Lost Ark
when he switches out the bag and the the
artifact the bag I think he has a he has
a mixed bag in there oh yeah
okay
one's the prologue that out it seems
like everyone's Keen to spoil for you
guys so I'm gonna do it right now too it
starts off in the 1940s setting up
everything to come you got this young
Indiana Jones and then you see how they
get their hands on half of the dial of
Destiny how it's being kept by the Nazis
led by mads Mickelson Indiana Jones has
teamed up with physical Wilder Bridge's
dad played by Toby Jones it's a prologue
that's supposed to feel like the old
Indiana Jones movies John you have way
more of a nostalgic love for Indiana
Jones than I do what did you think about
that prologue I thought the prologue was
decent kind of went halfway for me I
mean the first thing you notice
obviously is the de-aging technology on
Harrison Ford which at times looks
pretty amazing and at other times has
all the pitfalls that we've come to
expect from that particular effect but
that aside yeah it's a fun you know
clippy adventurous prologue it sets
everything up it you know is indicative
I think of the pace the rest of the
movie kind of has it moves it's sort of
a Breakneck kind of speed but there is a
lot of fun there there's a good sort of
imagination and a nice contained wrap
around to it all before the main Venture
sets off yeah it's like crazy that
Indiana is pulling off yes in this
adventure right Beyond just the de-aging
which did have this emotional journey of
wow that looks great to oh I don't know
about that too sometimes same shot being
like whoa that looks real wait his mouth
is moving that looks off that looks
really off and his voice sounds just as
old as he doesn't know Annunciation
ain't matching it this looks great when
you're not showing him talk I like it
when he's not talking yeah it was never
quite immersive because it was
constantly fluctuating between it and I
feel like a general audience member of
what he experiences I'm not just talking
about people with that critical lie I
did enjoy it I thought it ended up being
like a lot of fun it felt a little bit
like they were trying to capture the
spirit instead of genuinely being the
spirit there but for the most part you
know I'd be lying if I said I didn't
actually enjoy it but then I started to
love the movie because then we really
kick off act one where you step from
like the fantasy of Indiana Jones into
harsh old man reality of Indiana Jones
and the washed up old guy the first shot
of Harrison Ford of today minor spoiler
very vulnerable he is shirtless out of
shape cranky hung over he's in a
terrible mood on the day of his
retirement which also happens to be Moon
day the day the Americans reached the
moon all by ourselves with no help from
anyone from elsewhere in the world I
imagine maybe some people might react to
it with the oh my God are they Luke
skywalkering this are they Last Jedi or
Indiana Jones throw the whip over his
shoulder into stain I think it works
better here because of the fact that
Indiana Jones is just a human and being
and I loved the portrayal here because
they were setting up some really
interesting things I can't spoil for you
guys because there were some personal
life struggles that he's going through
here that raised a question mark of
stuff like what's going on with the
Indiana Jones's son what's going on with
Karen Allen they do acknowledge that it
really is intertwined with what Indiana
Jones is dealing with so I don't want to
give it away but I loved what they set
up and I loved the way it was all
playing out I loved the Aesthetics the
production design the whole vibe and
Aura in the mood and that's when you
meet Phoebe Waller Bridge's character
Helena who is his goddaughter and you
see this instant chemistry where there's
this twinkle back in Harrison Ford's eye
feeling good about the past and then she
wants to find the other half of the dial
of Destiny for a lot of her own reasons
right and then it leads into this
eventual people of course you know you
got like mads Mickelson you got Boyd
Holbrook they're all like chasing after
the same thing so they're chasing after
her that's where you see all that stuff
in the trailer with the big parade and
Indie on the horse and the train like
the main good stuff I loved it I mean
did you love I I see yeah like all of
that like the whole like that whole like
20 minute chunk that tension at Stakes
it had a rousing spirit to it I loved
all of it I was like I don't know what
all these critics are talking about yeah
this movie's a blast absolutely and it's
cool to see him in the 60s in a slightly
different context and setting you know
in the city all that stuff and then and
then you gotta get Indiana Jones
overseas across the world slowly but
surely everything about the movie
started to not work for me it started
feeling rote monotonous perfunctory like
the pacing started feeling dull
everything started feeling forced it
started feeling like James Mangold was
at a Crossroads between the kind of
movies he wanted to make because in the
beginning of it it seemed like oh he's
kind of doing a bit of like a Logan
approach but not like as heavy or
harrowing but with the Indiana Jones
backdrop you know and I thought that was
great because it was really clicky like
all the tone phones were just it was
perfect like what a great sequel setup
the legacy sequel great job and then
here it's like they set up all these
things with Indiana Jones being this
like elderly guy who's like been out of
the game and all these things and then
when he gets back overseas it's just
kind of like we're supposed to forget
about all that and he's just moving
along no problem and then more
importantly this is the pacing of it
just became so boring how would you
describe the I think we joked about it
in the middle of the movie of what the
basic structure was well yeah it's like
Indiana Jones will arrive at a place
he'll have an argument usually with
Phoebe Waller Bridge or somebody they'll
establish like the next destination or
the next McGuffin they gotta go get and
then oh man's Mickelson shows up and now
we gotta have a fight and now we gotta
move on to the next place and you'll
forget about mads Mickelson for a while
while they repeat that cycle and then
he'll show up again to be one step
behind everything in the recycle repeat
everything just started feeling like it
was trying to be Indiana Jones the old
movies instead of just being its own
thing which surprised me because I'm
like James mangle come on man Just Do
Your Own Thing through your dreams you
usually do Your Own Thing saying why am
why is this the least I have felt your
voice in a movie and you've done
franchise movies too and yeah I mean
with the mcguffins it just becomes on
now they got it and now we got it now
they got it now we got it and there's
not really much of like a visual flavor
or a dynamic to the pacing it's always
the characters yeah it moves in kind of
a mono type of pace that is just chop
chop chop and it feels very much a
victim of you know the modern
Blockbuster sensibility where I feel
like it really could have benefited from
some of the breathing room and the
tangibility that the original movies it
is trying to emulate had it takes you
across the world to all these exotic
locations but you don't really feel like
you're spending much time there and even
the tombs and the puzzles and stuff like
that are like pretty brief I would find
myself getting into a moment being like
yeah now this is Indiana oh oh we're
moving on okay here's what I'll say I
think Harrison Ford is excellent here
it's easy easily there's no question
about it he's doing great work it's his
most emotional performance of the
Indiana Jones films he really cares he's
not just showing up and pretending to be
and yet Joe it's like he really cares
and shows in this film shows in the
interviews and the press that he does
for it specifically this portrayal they
have some emotional moments here that I
thought they really could have played
into like there's a line in the trailer
where Harrison Ford he's saying it's not
about what you believe it's about how
hard you believe so you kind of think
that that's what this movie is going to
be about but no it's not uh like they
have a scene where they say it but it's
not really demonstrated yeah and nor
does that matter in this movie and I
mean the particular plot that they're
going after isn't something he is
especially passionate about as a
character exactly and that actually
undercuts a lot of the fun of the
journey because Harrison Ford himself
his whole purpose of going on this is
I'm just trying to clear my name for not
getting blamed for that happened
because I'm the tiger I just want to
sleep in my apartment enjoy my
retirement like he has no real vested
interest in this to like I need to the
trailers try to trick you into thinking
I've been looking for this all my life
this is the journey I never gotta finish
and now I'm going to finish it the
trailers are trying to tell you that but
that's not what's Happening Here the
movie tries to trick you to think it's
like doing this it's going to Crescendo
into this theme of something but nah no
no you get the crescendo moment without
the entire movie that ought to have
proceeded it to really sell what the
emotions of that real climax ought to be
Phoebe Waller Bridge that's what I feel
like you and I are kind of on a
disagreement here because I am 100
sexist and I agree with the entire sex
inside of the internet about oh my God
and I want her to be Indiana Jones yeah
that's what I was hoping for and we got
it it's not as cut and dry as that I
don't want a song I don't like her I
started off with oh she's Charming too I
don't like the way you're reading you're
kind of annoying to eventually within
like the last like 40 to 45 minutes of
this I really started to like her a lot
and I feel like she and Harrison Ford
have easily some of the best scenes in
this movie for sure close to the end of
this film by the end of it I really
liked her a lot yeah I like the two of
them together I thought the emotion of
that and just what they were at least
alluding to even if it wasn't always in
the dialogue and whatever just the aura
of their shared relationship was really
lovely and I liked her you know like
knowledgeable but feisty kind of persona
I feel like even though people love to
complain about that these days it's well
at home in a world like this and you can
see how she's reigniting that spark for
him I like that a lot and even her you
know having her own little short round
guy kind of made for a nice just
interesting beat for that character even
if that was nowhere near as engaging or
you know lovable as actual Short Round
yeah it was kind of okay it's more like
hey remember Short Round We got up we
had a much more restrained version here
we got a lot more restrained versions of
everything you remember and that's the
the thing is everyone's comparing this
to Crystal Skull and I'm like in some
ways Crystal Skull has more like flavor
and takes more swings and in some ways
this one is much more sort of akin to
what you want but really they both kind
of balance out to me by the end of the
day I would actually I would meet you on
that then you got mads Mickelson here
who is yes a ruthless cunning scientist
Nazi guy who was going forward this more
real like Menace gravitas portrayal like
you see mads Mickelson do in movies yeah
like you wanted him to go bigger which
feels like the plot could have warranted
it for sure yeah
that he's got going on here yeah yeah
and his obsession I just feel like you
know given that it's Indiana Jones I
don't mind a different take on a villain
but you know I mean escalated into
madness that's part of what we do here
yeah yeah I I can I can see where you're
coming from because again a lot of this
came down to its energy and it's feeling
like they were trying to capture the
spirit but it was dragging I think where
James Mangold and Company I don't really
know where this movie movie went wrong
for it because clearly like it went
around for a lot of people where I
thought they were trying to be a little
bit deceitful here a little manipulative
like they had this crazy cool action
scene in their first overseas car chase
that you see a lot of and the trailers
and I like the car sure it was it was
cool I didn't feel any like tension or
any but I know something was off and I
was like this doesn't feel genuinely
exciting this just feels like I'm
watching some cool shots here and there
but I don't find this exciting it's not
as tangible like I think India Indiana
Jones especially I think doesn't work
well swing monkey Vines just level but
yeah no but even that I'll forgive
because I'm like well you need CG for
that I guess but yeah they relied too
heavily on CG in these recent Indiana
Jones is where the previous ones would
have had to have made sure a lot of it
practically and then resorted to visual
effects yeah then any following action
scenes I don't even remember what really
happened honestly yeah they all just
started blending together and they don't
really distinguish themselves too much
so if you're able to have fun with this
movie like a lot of people who've been
able to come out of this film going I
don't care what critics because I
thought I was I thought I was becoming
that guy like I wanted to be in the
first like 30 minutes I was like oh my
God yeah I'm bad guy then as they're wet
I was like no this is this is tough this
is this is really boring this is a
really boring film because I'm bringing
up all the characters due to the fact
that this movie set up so many things
that it's not just Greg having like wish
like fulfillment needs it's with the
movie set up and I thought okay they've
sent us some interesting things here
mads Mickelson The prologue like wow
what a great way to to make him more
than just another Nazi this guy should
have a very personal Vendetta especially
after what happens to this guy no uh it
doesn't even seem like it's brought up
ever in the conversations with Phoebe
Waller bridge in him it just felt like
banter and not anything with real depth
until close to the end of this film it
feels like there were two drafts of this
that were very much at War and they're
like four credited writers it feels like
one of them was just the adventure and
just the plot beats and stuff and then
there was a different version where it's
like let's do the send-off ride into the
sunset you know embracing your age story
and I really feel like they kept one or
two three Beats from that personal story
and then mostly went with the big action
Blockbuster which is fine but these
movies are capable of doing both I know
people argue you don't come to Indiana
Jones for a drama or a character study
but with the amount of love the series
has garnered and the way it's tied to
Harrison Ford and with movies like
Maverick or even the John Wicks in
acknowledging the age of their stars and
letting them kind of break that fourth
wall they really missed an opportunity
to do that here like Harrison Ford's
portrayal of his Walk of Life at this
point is Indiana Jones is lovely when
you get to Glimpse it but they don't
spend much time on that however in the
finale and maybe some of you guys have
heard this this is when the movie
decides to try something different I
like the different thing they did I
thought there was a cool mood and aura
about it there were some great visuals
to it there's some emotional heft and I
really love the final scene of this
movie it's a great wraparound for this
specific journey of what Indiana is
going through in his personal life and
the adventure he just went on it's got
great Nostalgia beats to it in a way
that felt like I actually had to remind
myself like people started like
chuckling at least certain things that
were happening and I and I I I like I
said I'm not like massively in love with
the films so I had to like check myself
and go like what's oh yes that's what
that's what it is yeah yeah the Callback
right yeah yeah but that being said I
thought it was still working really well
for me even without immediately
recognizing what the Callback was in the
finale it doesn't necessarily redeem the
The Experience though while I can
isolate and go I like that show it's a
swing at least it was cool it was cool
it doesn't ultimately redeem the
experience that it left me with for the
mo for most of this film which was this
is disappointing I cannot underscore the
word trying even more than I can now it
is yeah you just feel the word trying so
it's busy and dense without being rich
yeah overall for me I would be like a 52
on this movie honestly like I cannot I
cannot say that over like that 50 that
percent that I'm recommend is like all
in the first half hour where I loved it
and then the the finale parts were like
yeah it was nice yeah sure sure I mean
yeah on a generous day I might go to
like 60 but really it is in that 50
range because I think some people as
demonstrated with a lot of the responses
some people gonna love it some people
are gonna feel like us and at the end of
it I just wasn't really moved a lot by
much so what is your favorite Indiana
Jones movie leave your thoughts down
below
um you can subscribe leave a like uh did
you like this one we will talk with you
all soon
[Music]
um